open to any trades um
those are those are conversations that
generally start to um to have a little
bit the higher you up in the draft
really the sooner the conversations uh
begin i have not had any trade
conversations with anybody as of yet
those usually tend to start in the
combine in the hallways that we kind of
roll through and we'll see how that goes
bob quinn lions general manager making
it clear that there is an opportunity to
trade down from the third overall pick
in the draft and look there's always an
opportunity to trade down to trade up
it's it's a commodity like anything else
and if you get an offer you can't refuse
you would be unwise to refuse it but
peter with the detroit lions and we
touched on the tuatanga by lower
possibility and the
possibility matthew stafford may want to
change the scenery the problem is that i
firmly believe matt patricia the head
coach bob quinn the gm are on notice
that things had better improve
significantly this year so you need to
emerge from the draft i think with guys
who can play right away we don't know
that tua can play right away you i but
but i i think that whether you stay at
number three or trade down and get more
lottery tickets and maybe get more guys
who can play right away which if that's
what you can do if you can dangle that
for a quarterback that somebody feels
compelled to come up and get and you get
those multiple players that can
contribute right out of the gates that
may help these guys stick around beyond
2020 in detroit
i think the biggest issue where detroit
is picking mike and let's just say that
the quarterback thing's a non-starter
and they have no interest in the
quarterback and they're going to keep
stafford so let's just say that that's
the case because that's likely all right
so now you start looking at
a guy like bob quinn cannot make that
decision you know on february 24th he
can make the decision maybe
you know on on april 4 but he can't make
it right now because he needs to know on
his draft board and let's just say for
the sake of argument he's you know
everybody's going to have joe burrow
he's not taking him anyway but then he's
going to have chase young far and away
his number one guy all right he can't
get chase young so now it gets to number
three in the draft and on his board he's
got five guys who are very close
and he says okay look we really like
okuda you know we love simmons this
versatile linebacker safety from clemens
we really like maki bechten you know the
monster tackle from louisville quicker
than a guy who's 370 pounds should be so
let's just say he gets to that point
and then let's just say that you know
the carolina panthers are dying to get
up to number three
well then you say okay carolina you can
have our pick we'll move down to number
seven and you give us your next two twos
and we'll do that and so i'm only making
this point to say that until you set
your draft board you can't know
what the value to your organization is
for the third pick in the draft
yeah that's right because if there's a
chance you can slide down a few spots
and still get the guy you would have
taken if you had to use the pick at
number three overall then it's a hell of
a deal you're paying him less you still
get him and you get some other stuff in
return that's why it's always important
to keep the cards as close to the vest
as possible because if you do trade down
you want to be able to say with a
straight face we got the guy we would
have taken if we had stayed where we
were so it's already a win no matter
what those extra picks turn into we're
getting him at a lower spot and we're
going to pay less we're going to have a
little more cap space available for
other positions but look we're going to
hear plenty about this and we we never
know when the trades are going to happen
ideally a trade happens when the picks
on the clock but we saw a couple of
years ago the jets pulled the trigger
and moved up from six to number three
to get themselves in position for one of
the top quarterbacks they just didn't
know who it was going to be but they
were fine with that and we may see
movement like that because when there's
a team that's ready to trade down and if
multiple teams are ready to trade up if
you want to trade up you better you
better pull the trigger even if you'd
rather wait until your picks on the
clock
mike and there's one other factor to
consider in this okay this is a big
quarterback draft you know there's
probably going to be three guys taken in
the top eight or ten okay so that
automatically
basically
increases the value of your pick because
when teams figure i gotta have that
quarterback what if matt rule the
carolina panthers coach wakes up on
april 1st and said guys we got to go get
justin herbert he's our guy it doesn't
matter where we have to go to get him we
got to go get him we don't know what the
next six weeks hold in all this draft
mayhem and all this pre stuff
that makes it even better
for the detroit lions to have three
quarterbacks in the top ten who are
probably going to get picked right
around there and if that happens all of
a sudden they got premium value at
number three
yeah and you just play it slowly and you
wait you wait you wait and you'll know
when that right offer rolls around the
time is right for us to take a quick
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports